hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the curse
of Blackwater okay so we're just about
to throw this switch which is gonna
cause all sorts of chaos to happen I'm
gonna run out and mean hey
hey buddy hey buddy buddy odd dammit I
can't open the door I see you over there
mister Necromorph man he activated the
emergency power has been activated okay
alright okay so what we need to do did
that happen before
did I ask a question like that before
that's what I need to know it now okay
so what needs to happen is I'm gonna go
through the main office area again
because I think I was able to go through
there pretty much did that happen before
that all happened before why am I being
startled like that again I I swear that
happened before anyway alright whatever
so what I need to do is I need to be
very careful in my coming through this
entire area because it's very easy to
possibly miss hey wait a minute
I think I said wait no nevermind those
are from slept good that happened before
- that happened before I remember that
why am I forgetting everything I just
played this yesterday okay I don't know
I'm an idiot
I'm not gonna be startled by things I've
been startled by already because that's
stupid don't do that okay got one key
card now I need to make sure that I open
all these cabinets because it could be
very easy to miss one
and there might be one on the desk and
I'm pretty sure that's the sound of a
mr. monster creeping up slowly but as I
realized before I was able to sneak by
with relative ease why there is a
cabinet like this in the bathroom I do
now no but there's a key in the toilet I
hear you I hear you mr. man are you in
that room close the door ha ha ha ha
you can probably open doors can't you oh
crap oh crap
Bubba no oh no I got stuck on aah that's
not fair that's not fair you can't do
that to me damn it you got me stuck in a
corner it's ok though too proud to be
stuck in corners and stopped like that
stupid eh oh all right oh no what I
shouldn't have done that
oh no no it's gonna gut me no he's gonna
get me oh no he's coming for me oh no ok
boo boo he activate ok startling noises
start in 3 2 1
it's the first one here's the second one
in my ear I need to learn to closed
doors behind me by the by and I'm gonna
assume that all these key cards are in
the same place for your silver that
happened before damn it [ __ ] me
god damn it yeah
all right anyway that happened Bo how
many times is that gonna get me before I
finally realize it I'm a giant wimpy man
baby that doesn't do anything right shut
up everybody
just shut up close the damn doors huh
okay yeah hang up that key the locker
key which is a locker to the locker at
the end of the hall I think okay so okay
he's in that I'm gonna I'm gonna close
this girl
oh-ho-oh trapped you in there buddy
it was Locker to one of these and it was
in here I think I believe I believe I
believe I want to believe that I am
wrong oh oh oh okay I'm okay
I closed him pretty good I think it was
do this one wasn't it wasn't it where's
the key card I know there was a key card
down here I got to I remember cannot I
could have sworn that it was to one of
these in Oh No well I got a battery but
that's not exactly gonna help me fight
the diabolical monsters close some
portal there we go it was right there I
knew it was right there I got okay looks
like we're in the clear and let's just
before anything else happens we're gonna
double-check he ain't gonna come this
way
we're very not cut very aha cabinet key
that's what I was looking for or was it
I don't know if I got that before anyway
I got a cabinet key he sounds kind of
close mister man where are you
don't don't come here bro
okay
all right he bashed down that door but
that's okay cuz i'ma go though
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha man he likes to
bash down doors that's ok new battery
all right
I don't know if I miss another cabinet
in there but dude you really do you lose
you're gonna go here's a comment is it
coming on through he's I'm movin on up
ok keep looking for key cards got to be
very careful that's a bottle of medicine
I'm gonna need when he stabs my face ok
this was the portal thing happening over
here no battery key office key cool I
can open up another thing in the other
office another battery awesome love it
love it baby
alright and hopefully I can lose the
movie stars chasing me around this Dias
Dyess deus deus ex machina okay sorry ah
us that's hey how's it going kind of
twitchy there still don't know why
they're doing experiments with the
babies or why a maternal hospital a
maternity hospital is the ideal place to
do transdimensional experimentation okay
is he coming back don't collision
keep going keep going mr. douche really
good
ah ah gonna get it go get me slam down
some medicine huh oh there's something
that's calming it we gotta get it I got
high coming it's gonna kill me Dad
he's gonna kill me Oh kill me bro
please please please please don't kill
me
please please don't kill me not killing
me would be awesome
am I gonna get away from him oh I've
gotten away from him before I know this
I know I have I know I did okay where do
you I don't know got it
another key card Oh Nikes I'm so boned
is there anything over your no oh no oh
come on be something here okay just he's
not chasing me anymore at least I don't
think so
ah
well I got three cards
I hear him over there I hear him over
there I didn't get a chance to look in
these things pretty closely so there's a
high probability that I have missed
something
or at least that's what I'm thinking
okay I'm gonna check that corpse over
here see if he's got a little some some
that looks like a keycard
oh come on come on oh come on I can't
crouch buddy
I can't crouch that looks like a keycard
and I want it ahahahahahaha I got it
okay
so where is oh I don't see him okay I'm
gonna just check this one cuz I think
this is the only one that I haven't
checked yet I've got an office key to go
to the other side but I'm very afraid
that I missed one in one of these rooms
here that's all closed
oh yeah going that yeah I'm in that room
oh yeah you got no oh no you're right on
top of me buddy as I close you in that
room ah
I'm the best I'm the best there ever was
I'm the best I'm officially the greatest
person ever what that wait you were just
in that room how tonight thought I heard
him over here how did he get over here
where's he going what's he doing what is
he doing I can't even see anything what
is he doing he like disappears and
reappears places how is that fair answer
is that it is not
where's go
okay where'd you go now buddy you you
just vanished is that what happened
really you just vanished
you decided oh I'm not gonna play by
your rules anymore
I'm gonna go wherever the hell I want
huh okay he's over there I need to get
to the office at the end of the hall
that was the only one that was locked
and hopefully that'll lead me to one
more key such that I can get out of here
okay what I'm gonna do is that my sneak
in this room here just so stealthily
Snell Philly and then I'm gonna loop
back around and wait for him to pass
that's right that's right buddy
that's right you got me Oh No
Oh No yes all right let's look for the
fifth key fifth key then I just need one
more there's no oh bathroom key okay
hopefully it's in there come on give me
a key gimmicky give me a key card
give me a key card you're not gonna fool
me digest a two key card in here okay so
that means last key card
we were right in front of me wait a
minute
well maybe that was farther away sounds
like he's wandering around to the other
rooms perfect that's good that's amazing
that's exactly what I want that is yes
yes now what do I do with that what do I
do with six I don't know what I do with
six what do I do with six I never stop
to think what I would do once I got this
many okay where is he okay I hear him I
think he's in the other room maybe I go
up these stairs because I remember I
went up these stairs before and I didn't
see what it was all about but maybe
there's something here now I can use
dammit nope uh-uh oh maybe I go back to
this area what did this guy's note say I
can't read it
nope hang on see fine six flood access
lower research labs how do I access the
lower research labs I don't know how to
access the law Razer's labs was this CVC
T closed-circuit television monitoring
facility I don't think it's in here but
nowhere to go I'm gonna die
oh I'm gonna die I'm gonna die cuz I
have no idea where I'm supposed to go
he's gonna kill me he's gonna chop off
my niblets I did serve him up forget her
he's gonna murder my face off okay all
right man up man up markiplier now or
never do or die just look at the signs
okay
main lab Sawa main office it had to be I
don't remember seeing anything about
lower research labs flooded AM sewers I
don't remember any of that but hopefully
he's oh oh oh here here yes ah God I did
it yes my mission is clear now the
portal must be closed there is no choice
even if it result in my own demise I was
reading that thank you very much
alright alright alright hahaha
what's that oh you can't get to me Oh
what alright alright well this isn't a
good thing
three dead scientists main lab that way
what's over here I'm actually just about
out of time so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna leave this delightful looking
place for the next episode so anyway
this is like just what I'm staring at
right now this should be a fun-filled
adventure that I'll never ever ever be
able to stop seeing in my dream so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done out
bye-bye
my god I have a string quartet
poor guy
wasn't that big
Oh
ah come on
the clothes